est
ce que vous saviez que lamb ailleurs
state building et frappé 23 fois par la
foudre chaque année
par contre ce n'est pas tellement de ça
dont je veux parler parce que bon lui le
vit plutôt bien mais vous est-ce que
vous avez déjà été frappé par la foudre
non sans doute pas ou alors très peu
d'entre vous est ce que vous savez ce
qu'ils vous arriverait si vous l'étiez
frappé par la foudre
oui vous êtes sûr moi je suis pas sûr
rester un petit peu on valoir faisons
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
montaner ans on s'imagine que si on est
frappé par la foudre on meurt sur le
coup qu'on acquiert des super pouvoirs
seulement si on est dans un comics
indonésie
dans les deux cas c'est pas tellement
vrai mais perso je vous déconseille
d'essayer ou alors peut-être commencer
par des fermes mordre par une araignée
radioactive est encore bon bref on va
voir ça tout de suite mais avant de
commencer petit flash spécial
flash un port cette vidéo est sponsorisé
par cider ghost rider gosses c'est un
vpn est ce que je vous fait l'affront de
vous expliquer ce que c'est un vpn aller
oui vite fait un des pnc un réseau privé
virtuel mais en anglais donc les lettres
sont pas les mêmes en gros quand vous
faites vos petites affaires sur internet
ça masque votre ip ça chiffre vos
données et sahar dirige tout ça vers un
réseau sécurisé concrètement ça veut
dire que si vous êtes en vacances chez
votre mémé qui a déménagé à l'étranger
pour sa retraite par exemple eh ben ça
vous permet de débloquer des trucs
auxquels vous n'auriez pas accès en
temps normal de cuche et z comme les
programmes que vous voulez regarder sur
les plateformes de streaming vidéo par
exemple et bien sûr ça marche aussi si
vous n'êtes pas chez n'aimait que vous
soyez chez vous ou dans un lieu public
comme un café une gare etc avec le vpn
vous pouvez faire vos recherches en
ligne de manière anonyme mais sans
risque de vous faire piquer vos données
personnelles et vous pouvez vous
géolocaliser dans le monde entier et
débloquer les contenus des plates formes
dont on vient de parler par exemple en
tout il ya 7500 serveurs dans 90 pays
différents où que vous soyez vous pouvez
avoir accès à ce que vous et personne ne
sait ce que vous faites de vos soirées
parce que les données ne sont pas
conservées c'est facile à utiliser dont
vous pourrez même prêté votre ordi à
votre mémé pour qu'elle regarde sa série
et si vous avez peur qu'elle fouine dans
vos dossiers elle pourra même le faire
sur le sien parce que sai burgos vous
pouvez l'utiliser sur cet appareil
différents en même temps et c'est
compatible avec windows mac et ios
android les smarttv linux et les
consoles de jeux voilà je pense que ceux
qui connaissaient pas encore on comprit
maintenant qu'est ce que je peux vous
dire d'autre que ça hyper gosses c'est
l'un des leaders mondiaux des vpn que
c'est l'un des plus recommandés sur 13
paille locke & key à plus de 38 millions
d'utilisateurs peut-être si vous avez
envie d'essayer vous avez 84 % de
réduction sur votre abonnement c'est à
dire que vous payez
1,94 euro par mois et en plus vous avez
quatre mois gratuit pour ça je vous ai
vu un lien dans la description de la
vidéo vous avez juste à cliquer dessus
et à vous laisser guider et si vous avez
une question vous pouvez contacter le
support 24 heures sur 24 et 7 jours sur
7 il parle français si au final vous
êtes convaincu d'être mieux moi je suis
ravi sinon vous avez la garantie 45
jours satisfait ou remboursé donc vous
pouvez y aller tranquille le lien est
dans la description mais revenons-en à
la foule d'après météo-france la foudre
tombe 450 mille fois par an même s'il ya
d'autres estimations qui parle du double
et le nombre de cas de personnes
foudroyées il varie entre 100 et 300
selon les sources est ce que ça veut
dire que la foudre du tout les ans en a
300 personnes en france et va non pas du
tout contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait
penser quand on est frappé par la foudre
on ne meurt que dans 10 % des cas alors
je dis que dans 10 % des cas mais bon on
se comprendre quand on est dans les 10 %
on est 100 % mort donc devant du coup la
foudre ait eu rarement mais 70% des
personnes qu'elles frappent garde quand
même des écarts mais en fait qu'est ce
qui se passe exactement si vous avez été
frappé par la foudre pour comprendre ça
il faut d'abord savoir ce que c'est
exactement la foudre on a longtemps
pensé que c'était une manifestation de
la colère divine
au cours des siècles il ya plein de
personnes plus ou moins savante qui ont
élaboré des théories plus ou moins
scientifiques jusqu'à ce que benjamin
franklin imagine sa fameuse expérience
du cerf-volant pour vérifier une
intuition qui l'avait à l'époque son
hypothèse c'est que la foudre c'est ni
plus ni moins que de l'électricité donc
il dit j'attends qu'il ya un orage je
sors mon petit cerveau l'ange l'envoi
dans les nuages je mouille bien la corde
pour que ce soit conducteur en barre
j'accroche un truc métallique et
j'attends de voir si ça fait des
étincelles s'il frappé par la foudre
alors à la base lui ça à moitié comme
une blague mais tout le monde le prend
au sérieux donc le 15 juin 1752 il tente
le coup et ça marche ça fait des
étincelles c'est considéré comme
l'invention du paratonnerre mais ça
permet surtout de vers c'est un truc
qu'on sait aujourd'hui la foudre c'est
de l'électricité pour la petite histoire
quelques mois plus tard il ya un
scientifique russe qui s'appelle georges
guillem reichmann qui lira un petit peu
plus loin dans l'expérimentation mais
bien malgré lui en essayant de refaire
une expérience à peu près du même genre
il a tout bonnement été foudroyé et il
est mort sur le donc la foudre c'est de
l'électricité qui se forment dans les
nuages en gros à l'intérieur des nuages
à cause des mouvements des masses d'air
il ya des particules qui se déplace très
vite qu'ils se frottent qui entrent en
collision etc il ya une partie de ces
particules qui se chargent positivement
qui va vers le haut des nuages et
l'autre partie qui se chargent
négativement et qui va vers le bas des
nuages et la différence de potentiel ça
crée une décharge électrique qui va
essayer de rééquilibrer tout ça si ça
reste au niveau des nuages c'est juste
des éclairs mais si ça descend jusqu'au
sol la première c'est la foule mais
attention cette décharge d'électricité
statique elle a pas du tout les mêmes
caractéristiques que l'électricité que
produisent des humains donc oui être
frappé par la foudre c'est une forme
d'électrocution mais ça prouve pas du
tout les mêmes lésions que si on met les
doigts dans la crise ne fait pas ça
c'était un message de prévention pour
vous faire une idée on estime que la
foudre c'est une décharge de 20 villes
en perd 10 à 100 millions de volts et
que ça chauffe l'air autour jusqu'à
trente mille degrés celsius donc c'est
hyper violent mais c'est hyper court
c'est de l'ordre de la micro secondes
voire de la milliseconde mais pas plus
et il ya plusieurs façons d'être rappelé
alors on peut être foudroyé par ce qu'on
appelle un éclair latéral la foudre elle
fera un objet nous on est à côté il ya
un éclair qui seraient entre l'objet et
nous et bien non c'est pour ça qu'il
faut pas se réfugier sous un arbre quand
il ya de l'orage par exemple ensuite la
foudre elle peut frapper le sol
directement et nous vu qu'on est debout
de suba on se prend une bonne décharge
c'est ce qui peut arriver au bétail par
exemple ou aux joueurs de foot
un peu dans le même registre si on est
en train de toucher un objet quand il
est frappé par la foudre et là on prend
deux doses aussi et pour finir bien sûr
on peut être foudroyé directement la
foudre elle nous tombe dessus sur la
tête souvent elle parcourt tout le corps
et vous vous doutez bien que ça fait son
petit effet la ddt pour être tout à fait
complet pour des raisons qu'on comprend
pas encore complètement la foudre elle
peut aussi prendre la forme d'une boule
de ceux qui finit en général par
exploser dans son coin dans une odeur de
soufre
mais qui peut aussi frapper des gens au
passage c'est rare c'est pas très
documenté mais a priori c'est un vrai
truc c'est même ce qui aurait tué
georges guillem reichmann vous souvenez
de
bons mais il se passe quoi dans notre
corps quand on est foudroyé eh ben on a
une idée assez précise de tout ça grâce
à l'adq et renault pathologie arnos la
foudre pathologie connaissez déjà vous
vous en doutez les conséquences vont pas
être les mêmes en fonction de la façon
dont vous avez été frappé enfin je dis
vous je ne vous souhaite pas répondre et
si vous êtes touché par un éclair
latéral la quantité d'énergie qui vous
arrive sera moins importante donc
potentiellement saha ferment de dégâts
si ça passe par le sol le courant il va
essentiellement passée d'une jambe à
l'autre sans monter jusqu au thorax donc
sans remonter jusqu'au coeur si vous
êtes frappé directement là par contre là
le point d'entrée ce sera la partie qui
est la plus proche du ciel donc a priori
la tête ou la main qui vous levez la
main et le point de sortie ce sera ce
qui est en contact avec le sol donc a
priori les pieds du coup vous avez
compris dans ces cas là c'est énergie
maximale et l'électricité traverse tout
corps dans ces cas là le plus gros
risque c'est l'arrêt cardiaque nos
coeurs c'est un appareil électrique il a
même une petite batterie qui est là en
haut à droite qui s'appelle le noeud
sinusal et qui envoie à un rythme
régulier des impulsions électriques qui
vont déclencher les contractions des
muscles cardiaque saleh comme les trucs
de muscu ses muscles en se contractant
ils pompent le sang qui à l'intérieur du
coeur c'est ce qui lui permet de
circuler et d'aller nourrir tous nos
sens ça c'est en temps normal mais quand
le coeur est traversé par le courant
électrique de la foudre le risque c'est
le court jus
en fait il ya deux possibilités soit les
impulsions électriques s'arrête
complètement et là il faut faire
repartir le coeur en injectant de
l'adrénaline soit le coeur se met à
envoyer plein de petites impulsions
électriques de façon complètement
anarchique qui sont pas suffisantes pour
que les muscles se contractent de façon
efficace ça s'appelle une fibrillation
et là il faut essayer de reset tout ça
en envoyant un autre choc électrique
externe mais cette fois avec ce qu'on
appelle un défibrillateur mais dans les
deux cas le résultat est le même le
coeur ne pond plus le sens donc il faut
faire un massage cardiaque externe ça on
en avait déjà parlé dans une série de
vidéos je vous remets les liens
formez-vous aux premiers secours donc ça
c'est le plus grand risque parce qu'il
ya une menace vitale immédiate mais
malheureusement si on en réchappe ou
n'est pas tirés d'affaires pour autant
d'abord parce qu'il ya des cas qui ont
été rapportés dans lesquelles les
personnes qui ont été foudroyées au fait
un infarctus plusieurs heures après le
choc et aussi parce qu'il ya le risque
d'avoir des séquelles cardiaques à long
terme et puis parce que c'est pas le
coeur qui flanche en premier c'est les
muscles respiratoires mais au final
mêmes conséquences quand on respire plus
le coeur fini par s'arrêter là l'autre
truc auquel on pense tout de suite avec
la foudre c'est les brûlures soit parce
qu'à la base on s'imagine que c'est une
espèce d claire de ce qui nous tombe
dessus soit parce qu'on sait que cette
électricité etc on sait que les
électrocutions ça provoque des brûlures
souvent des brûlures profondes sauf que
là comme on l'a vu à la différence d'une
électrocution classique c'est très très
court donc ça n'a pas le temps de
provoquer tout ça en fait les brûlures
elles sont pas systématiques et elles
sont assez particulières en général
elles sont assez superficiel et elles
ont des formes bizarres comme la forme
dite en feuilles de fougères cette forme
est pourrait s'expliquer par le trajet
du courant qui suit le truc le plus
conducteur qui trouve à savoir les
petits vaisseaux sanguins superficielles
ça donne ses trucs qui ressemble un
petit peu a des éclairs et aussi un
petit peu à une carte france des cours
d'eau et de leurs factures dans un autre
registre si vous portez une ceinture
avec un élément en métal par exemple ou
en fonction de la matière dans laquelle
sont fait bêtement tout ça ça peut
fondre et ça peut aussi provoquer des
brûlures et pour finir il peut aussi
d'avoir des brûlures plus profonde et
plus grave en général elle correspond
aux points d'entrée et au point de
sortie de la foule souvent ça ressemble
à des points qui sont pas très grands
qui sont généralement rond mais pas
forcément et qui peuvent être très noir
mais en réalité le problème principal
avec le foudroiement c'est les troubles
neurologiques s'entretuent reprises le
cerveau et tout le système nerveux aime
pas tellement se prend une grosse
décharge déjà parce que lui aussi il
fonctionne notamment grâce à des signaux
électriques qui se transmettent de neuro
dans le rhône et puis aussi parce que
sur son passage dans le corps le courant
fait des dégâts dans les cellules le
premier effet est classique dans les
gros choc c'est la perte de connaissance
parfois ça dure juste quelques minutes
mais ça peut aller jusqu'au coma en cas
de lésions cérébrales dans tous les cas
quand on se réveille on se souvient
souvent plus grand chose et c'est
peut-être pas plus mal comme ça et selon
le trajet de la foudre à l'intérieur du
corps et les dommages qu'elle a créée au
niveau du système nerveux ça peut aussi
entraîner d'autres séquelles qui vont
des paresthésies c'est à dire des
fourmis jusqu'à la paralysie c'est à
dire une parole une paralysie qui peut
prendre différentes formes qui peut
disparaître rapidement ou s'installer
plus longtemps et qui est causé par la
teinte des nerfs évidemment mais qui
peut aussi être la conséquence de petit
caillou qui se forme comme dans les
années c'est ça c'est pour les gros
danger mais la foudre a peut aussi faire
d'autres types de dégâts dans le corps
de celles et ceux qu'elle fera en
fonction des organes qui sont touchés
sur son passage à l'intérieur du corps
qui est différent selon le type de
foudroiement comme on l'a vu
l'électricité il peut causer des lésions
qui peuvent être graves au niveau des
muscles au niveau des eaux mais aussi au
niveau de certains organes par exemple
les yeux et les oreilles ils peuvent
être abîmée soit par le choc électrique
soit par d'autres caractéristiques de la
foudre comme l'intensité lumineuse pour
les yeux ou les décibels pour les
oreilles oui parce qu'on va quand même
de 120 à 130 décibels ce qui est
généralement considéré comme le seuil de
douleur avec des dangers immédiats mais
manqua de courte exposition au bruit en
question donc les conséquences elles
peuvent être immédiate ou arrivée dans
un deuxième temps donc pour les oreilles
ça peut être par exemple une perforation
des tympans des acouphènes voire une
surdité et pour les yeux des lésions de
la rétine ou de la cornée une cataracte
voire des troubles de la vision des
couleurs
donc tout ça c'est les conséquences
directes de la foudre mais il ya aussi
les cas où les personnes qui sont
foudroyés elles sont projetés par la
puissance du choc et elles peuvent aussi
se blesser comme ça de manière indirecte
à peuvent se faire des fractures par
exemple et bien sûr vous vous en doutez
il ya aussi les conséquences
psychologiques qui peuvent par exemple
aller jusqu'au syndrome de stress post
traumatique donc vous voyez la foudre
elle tue plutôt rarement mais sans
surprise donc des si on peut éviter
c'est mieux alors bon par contre le
problème c'est que par définition ça
prévient pas tellement
mais il ya quand même quelques trucs à
faire ou à éviter pour éviter que ça
vous arrive je vous mets tous les liens
vers les conseils dans la description
d'un lion vous aurez noté que je n'ai
fait aucune vannes de type ans le coup
de foudre genre a été un point commenté
amoureux
j'espère que vous en êtes reconnaissants
n'hésitez pas à me témoigner votre
gratitude dans les commentaires voilà
dtc c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles
vidéos d'ici là prenez soin de vous et
prenez soin des autres mettez vous bien
et surtout
portez vous bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]